a visibly scared Donald Trump
flipped out during a Gala the other day
over a special Council being selected by
Merrick Garland to investigate his
crimes you have to see Trump at this
thing he was in rare form and I don't
mean because he was wearing a tuxedo and
looking more orange than ever although
that was notable and interesting to see
Trump saying isn't this all kind of like
double jeopardy impeachment and by the
way I apologize for the terrible audio
that's an issue in the room apparently
the audio text must have been antifa
and they tried it in the Senate they
went through the whole process and we
won we went through the whole process so
wouldn't this sort of be a
and then you take a look at the other we
went through two of them and this is
just sort of like double jeopardy in the
old days they used to call it double
jeopardy but essentially uh we've done
so well and we did well in a very
hostile cup yeah
um it's not Double Jeopardy Double
Jeopardy is the prosecution of a person
more than once for the same offense
Trump thinks Double Jeopardy is they
keep finding out of new crimes you might
have committed and those crimes are
investigated he's clearly scared he's
clearly making no sense and there was a
hilarious statement actually that Trump
gave to Fox digital where he said quote
I have been proven innocent for six
years on everything from fake
impeachment to Mueller who found no
collusion and now I have to do it more I
am not going to partake in it I announce
and then they appoint a special
prosecutor the appointment of the
special prosecutor right after he
announces is the proper thing to do not
doing it would be a problem and of
course Trump is wrong that he has been
proven innocent he doesn't seem to
understand how anything Works uh he also
was impeached for things that they
weren't fake they mostly happened in
public and they're recorded
um Mueller did not find no collusion
Mueller decided not to prosecute and
Trump's saying he won't partake won't
really do anything it doesn't make it go
away back to the gala
Trump commenting on the special counsel
he said I thought that was case closed
this horrendous abuse of power is the
latest in a long series of witch hunts
he started a long time ago I thought the
investigation with the document hoax was
dying or dead or over and the
investigation into January 6 and my very
peaceful and patriotic speech remember
peaceful and patriotically
was dead especially after the
record-setting 40 Point loss of Liz
Cheney in the great he seems to think
that because Cheney lost the
investigation the criminal investigation
is over I mean just a total lack of
understanding of anything
I thought that put the final nail in the
coffin
only to find out that the corrupt and
highly political justice department just
appointed a super radical left special
counsel better referred to as a special
prosecutor to start the process all over
again we thought it was this guy's
scared you can genuinely tell there is
absolutely fear there and then he went
into his bizarre hyperbole like saying
there's no one more innocent than Trump
I've proven to be one of the most honest
and innocent people ever in our country
has proven to be one of the most honest
and innocent people ever in our country
Trump speaking at the same Gala actually
brought up uh Carey Lake and said what
happened with her is incredible and that
that isn't even over check this out
Carrie Lake who just went through an
incredible election
there were a lot of broken voting
machines you heard that and lots of them
happened to be in largely Republican
areas and uh what happened there is a
disgrace but I want to just tell you you
did some job carry and I know it's not
over yet it is over it is over and there
were a few tabulators that for a period
of time were not working in some parts
of Maricopa County uh everything was
fixed the GOP which had filed a lawsuit
retracted the lawsuit Kerry Lake lost it
is over uh Donald Trump also started
calling for the feds to invade the homes
of the clintons and the bushes which was
a very strange moment they have to
invade this is Mar-A-Lago they have to
invade Hillary and Bill Clinton's
beautiful home in Westchester they have
to invade the Bush's home they have to
invade a lot of homes
but they didn't do that and they took
documents they took a lot of things and
that's what we have the presidential
records act for hmm calling for you know
it's funny on the one hand he says law
enforcement and the FBI have been
politicized and weaponized and now he's
saying they should do it to the bushes
and clintons even though they aren't
actually invest under investigation for
any crimes and then lastly this is just
kind of funny
even C-SPAN pulling away from coverage
of this Chicago recently
that 82 people shot 82 over a weekend
but they said it was a long weekend Oh
okay that's better
[Music]
[Applause]
it was a long weekend
in Afghanistan
when I was in charge we didn't have one
killing think of it in 18 months now one
of our soldiers were killed and then you
look at Chicago and you look at other
things
former president Trump has moved on to
other topics we'll take this opportunity
to move on with our program schedule
that's the best other topics Trump's
entire speeches are moving on are moving
on to other topics that's all he does
move on to other topics so absolutely
surreal he looks terrified he looks
genuinely terrified we will have all of
these clips on our Instagram and
remember we are preparing for 2024 as
well pushing for 2 million YouTube
subscribers last month more than three
million different YouTube viewers
watched Clips but didn't subscribe help
us get to 2 million simply by hitting
the Subscribe button right now
if you are not yet subscribed to the
channel we could do it overnight just
with our existing viewers if they hit
that subscribe button help us out we're
going to take a quick break and be back
with so much more we're going to talk
about the runoff we're going to talk
about VP so many different things
check out our sponsor Shaker and Spoon
the monthly cocktail subscription box
that delivers the craft cocktail
experience to your door each monthly box
comes with three original recipes
created by world-class bartenders with
ingredients for 12 cocktails my favorite
is the blood and Sage it's part of the
Vodka based drinks it uses herbed Sage
syrup and blood orange Meyer lemon
ginger ale delicious refreshing I love
how Shaker and Spoon includes everything
you need the ingredients the
instructions right in the Box the recipe
is easy to follow the blood and Sage
made for a very relaxing fall afternoon
on the back deck a lot of fun with
Shaker and Spoon you don't need to seek
out hard to find cocktail ingredients or
buy full-size containers of things
you'll use once this is way more
convenient Shaker and Spoon introduces
you to spirits and flavor combinations
you may never have otherwise discovered
and it is a fantastic holiday gift give
the gift of an awesome experience Shaker
and Spoon giving you twenty dollars off
your first box go to shakerandspoon.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below